Nevada's prisons director calls in two
outside agencies to investigate the
circumstances surrounding one man's
death a new investigator Vanessa Murphy
has been uncovered issues with the state
prison system has more now and the
latest on the mystery within Prison
Walls
honor of death are pending what we do
know so far is several officers use
batons on the inmate less than 48 hours
before he died this is a photo of 44
year old Christian Walker the Nevada
Department of Corrections tells me he
was originally housed at Southern desert
Correctional Center he had run from
officers there and was then moved to
High Desert State Prison considered
maximum security officers claim he
didn't comply after he arrived and
that's when officers used Force again
multiple officers with batons so much so
we've learned at least one officer was
injured that was on April 13th we've
learned Walker died two days later
director James arenda just returned to
head the Prison System earlier this year
I interviewed him in February he
insisted the department would be more
transparent in this case he's asked the
Nevada Department of Public Safety and
the Attorney General's office to
investigate immediately I think
transparency is a big deal to me might
not have been with the last
Administration but I think the public
should be part of the part of this too
as for those officers involved the
Department of Corrections says no action
has been taken as far as any leave or
disciplinary action because the
investigations are ongoing Walker was
serving a life sentence for
second-degree murder returned strong the
advocacy group tells me they had been
working with Walker to try to get him
pardoned because of the circumstances
surrounding the crime this is a
developing story numerous sources from
both inside and outside the prison have
been reaching out to me we are actively
trying to piece together how Walker died
reporting in Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now Vanessa thank you and Vanessa
has been in contact with Walker's mother
she says she is too distraught to speak
right now but she believes officers used
excessive force against her son Again
Vanessa is working to piece all of this
together